it's only the first week of 2023 yet
never before has a salary gap between
those on the street and the CEOs and
their skyscrapers been so wide I'm like
at this point Eat the Rich you know just
Eat the Rich that would be a pricey
dinner the average pay for a Canadian
top 100 CEO a record 14.3 million
dollars or 243 times what a typical
Canadian worker makes up from 227 in
2018. I mean
it's their CEO right they're up there
for a reason so they must be doing a lot
to be able to get that much in fact at
the Canadian Center for policy
Alternatives found that many CEOs took
pay cuts during the pandemic but only to
their base salaries you'd think that CEO
pay would go down and it didn't when
studying the list of top CEOs you can
see how the majority of their
compensation is tied to perks based on
company performance which is somewhat
misleading because variable paid deals
guarantee a minimum bonus with no cap on
the upside at the top is Philip Fair of
Nuvi with a base salary of 818 thousand
dollars yet he pulled in 140 million
and while inflation has many Canadians
seeing red the highest earners only see
green the impacts of inflation are
completely different on the workers it
eats away at their purchasing power on
the CEO side it's boosted corporate
profits and therefore boosted their pay
inflation has been great for CEO pay the
CCPA have suggested a number of
solutions to shrink the Divide including
a wealth tax which not all economists
agree would work the Ontario living wage
network has taken a different approach
convincing 550 CEOs in the province
including 41 on the top 100 list to
guarantee a certified living wage for
their employees there are Executives out
there they're not uh the same not taking
the same approach as the ones that are
listed in this report they are are the
kind of Executives that decide to
certify as uh living wage employers and
that's proving to be a far better
strategy than Eat the Rich microlight
Global News Toronto